[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm right and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna be going down
the rabbit hole we have an envelope here
it's sealed inside of it is a question
from a mythical beast
I can almost read it but I don't but I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait
it's gonna begin a conversation that
could go anywhere left right down uh-oh
it's gonna go down North East down in
the hole before we open that envelope
though yeah I I would just ask if you
would allow me to share a big milestone
that is about to happen in my life
what okay we'll ask me then would you
mind if I shared a joyous occasion which
is happening days from now that is a
milestone in my life I'd rather you not
know sure go ahead every day when I get
home I pull up in my driveway and I turn
off my car and I reach up and I push the
button to open my garage door you open
your garage door there's not even a car
in there that's right what are you doing
there
I use it to enter the house I walk
through the garage and then I walk
through the door that's inside of the
garage to get in my house as opposed to
walking just to the left of the garage
and going in the front door now you do
realize you use significantly more
electricity to entering I know I know
that this is this is a concern of yours
as someone who really cares about energy
efficiency well the garage door opening
is much less energy efficient than you
walking ten more feet to go to the front
door but you can do whatever you want to
because I don't don't try to mess up my
milestone because what I do is then I
close the garage door behind me and
that's where my shoes are kept there at
the at the door from the garage into the
house you take your shoes off in the
garage I take my shoes
off in the garage I put on my my
slippers and then I go in the hell I'm
like mr. Rogers put on my put on my
sweater and then I go in the house of
Mike hello wife and kids and dog daddy's
home and every morning when I get up to
come to work I exit that way I exit
through the house into the garage
and I put on my shoes and if I'm going
to the gym I put on my heavy coat
because I'm cold nature and I like I
wear a heavy you know your coat in the
garage as well there's a coat rack in
the garage and then I want to interject
you do realize you're strange I mean
it's cool I respect every bit of it and
I'm glad that it makes you happy but you
do understand that I've gotten used to
the thing that makes me have no some of
the things that you just described I
would if I didn't know you I'd be like
hmm
I'd be like what else am I gonna find
out about this guy well peeps his coats
and his shoes in his garage insists on
entering through this portal and
changing it to a different portal portal
that's a good word I treat it like my
Sports unusual unusual is great I'm just
I'm just making I do you know that it's
unusual well before I answer that let me
add this just as a side note when I get
to the gym I take off my coat and I turn
it inside out okay I hang it oh hang it
on a hook in the gym and I then I work
out get all sweaty then I put on my coat
inside out and then I and then I go out
to my car I get my keys from the inside
what is now an internal pocket of my
coat because of how I'm wearing it I
crank up my car and I Drive home when I
get home I opened the garage door I
enter my portal I take off the coat and
turn it right-side out and hang it back
on the hook I understand thereby keeping
all the sweaty link me on the outside on
the outside of the cup let me just say
in the next morning I'm putting the
unswayed you understand I respect it I
think that it's completely obvious it's
all justified it's all very well thought
out
but I just learned something about you
and ice like this weird insight after
knowing you all this time some time
haven't gotten to the milestone yet but
going sometimes I look at you as I'm
speaking or as other people are speaking
and I can tell that you're not present
oh I thought you with pride with that
too and um just look tear and yeah and
sometimes that I'm not that I'm not a
nice name feel like yes and I feel like
I asked the question to myself you know
we spend a lot of time together I think
I asked this question to myself 27 to 29
times a week what is like thank you
and you're coming up with these freaking
systems is this what's going on when
we're in the middle of something and not
and then you're just gone are you like
thinking about I gotta turn the jacket
inside out that's it maybe is that what
the brain is that we're all the brain
powers going to these systems because I
mean that's a great system I totally get
it
I mean yeah I think people out there
gonna be like I'm gonna do the
inside-out coat thing I understand it's
completely logical it's just it's
interesting that you do you've got such
the systems are so intact and so
developed well it's ironic because it's
supposed to free me up for efficiencies
for other things in life like not having
to wash my coat or worry about because
that's a big problem for a for Americans
well there's a best way to do everything
and I'd coat washing my industrial
engineering degree I don't know if it
planted this information or if I acted
today I was attracted that discipline
because of the way my brain thinks so
systematically superior to people that I
podcast with and as a child I had no I
didn't know this about you we didn't
write I mean I talked I wrote in the
book of mythicality that like I petted
my dog Tucker
five times on the head but you didn't
share that with me I didn't know no I
didn't share that with anybody
he said not even Tucker he knew dogs can
count to three I think it's been proven
so this portal is a special place to me
because it is it is yeah I'm so glad you
called it a portal
like a holodeck it's like because it
transfers me into the world and then
back into my safe nest it's like the
bridge well it's like the bridge what is
the place on Star Trek with you material
a holodeck now the holodeck is where you
go to experience like a virtual reality
but what is it called where you they
beam you up I really like Star Wars Star
Trek is the thinking so thinking man
Star Wars Star Trek is the thinking man
Star Wars yep you heard it here Gene
Roddenberry oh gosh so it's a special
place to mean the washer and dryer are
all we are also in there I've seen them
I will say that as well as all the
cabinetry that was in my house when I
first bought it in the kitchen and it
was ugly so we we put it in the garage
right put it in the portal we also have
all the rugs on the floor of the garage
that we no longer wanted in the house
for whatever decorating reasons no
longer fit in the house yeah there's a
lot of thought that's going into it I
have noticed that so it kind of looks
like a yurt in there there's like like
mal matching rugs just everywhere but
there's also a couple of things which
have plagued me I cannot stand walking
through what I believe to be I thought
my domain now it's my portal to and from
the world it's cluttered I mean nobody I
mean there's a lamp three lamps
chair different stuff there's a recliner
that some friends let us borrow when
Lily was going through a back surgery
that now she doesn't need so we they
don't want it back and they haven't come
and pick it up so it's in the garage
there's a there's a go-kart that I
bought for the kids from a neighbor
because we could drive it on our street
because it's a private street legally
they never got into it and there's a
carrier that I I bought to put on top of
our car to hold luggage so that we could
all go somewhere as a family it's big
especially when you're just right next
to another girl and I'm like as and I'm
I'm I can't get out of my portal walking
around all this stuff and I'm seeing it
twice a day at least
especially in slavish it became it
came to symbolize clutter b'keen comes
to symbolize everywhere in my life but
specifically here in my portal just a
lack of control over my life and I just
cannot walk through that multiple times
a day and I will tell you that today
somebody came and picked up that go-kart
because for for a whole year I've been
like I'm gonna get rid of this go-kart I
put it on Craigslist no I put it on
Craigslist $200 our best offer within an
hour somebody's calling to come get it
within an hour I could have done this a
year ago that what are these people who
wants a go-kart in Los Angeles did you
communicate with the Craigslist contact
uh
burned our phone I got Jenna to talk to
him okay so I did not personally talk to
him because I didn't I didn't want to
bring that into the mix and I didn't
want to be there when they picked it up
because I didn't want them to know this
is my house you didn't want to say go
cart owned by Linc meal maybe I could've
got more money but I had gotten 350 I
didn't want to do 50 my house you don't
really like people come to your house
off Craigslist but how was that
desperate to get rid of Emma Starbucks
drive the go-kart to Starbucks the
moment we post someone's like I've got
I've been looking I've been waiting for
one of those or whatever or everybody's
in the market for a go-kart I'm in the
market you didn't even tell me or so and
then we you know what we loaded up the
recliner and got it out of there and
just returned it to people so what you
we're not gonna keep asking you to come
get it the loaner recliner we're gonna
bring it to you tomorrow this is gonna
be over cuz that's been there that's
been ten months they didn't just pawn it
off and they were like okay they kind of
did obviously I didn't want it cuz it's
been there for ten months I didn't want
they didn't want the recliner but I
didn't need anymore cuz their daughters
is good recovered as well yeah but he
had it in his office
okay got rid of that and I bought up a
rope hoist put that up and it holds the
carrier and it levitates it above the
garage door that sounds dangerous
well it's out off the floor I could
literally I know this sounds crazy yeah
we've been there for a while
what I'm about to say sounds crazy
I could literally park a car in my
garage but you don't want to do that
just just think about that for a second
know that this nobody does that in
California
nobody does out anywhere with a garage
yes unless unless you live in like
frigid places in your head well that's a
lot of places okay okay that's fair yeah
don't you don't forget so soon what the
weather is like that's true in other
places but nowhere where weather is not
a factor does anybody use the garage
other than keeping all the crap that
they don't want in their house well you
know what any place is too cold places
and rainy places we don't have cold we
don't have any tough though I know it's
tough for everybody even if you got rain
to keep the clutter out of there and and
I guarantee you what I'm gonna do what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna drive my car
and I'm a parking in there and then but
doesn't fading the portal I'm gonna do
it once just say I did it and then you
know what the next day is gonna be
something there I Drive over a slipper
three years ago three years ago I got
the garage clean enough right when we
moved in and I I was so proud I went in
the house and I was like Christie you
got to come out here and see this and
she was like I'm in the middle of summer
I'm like no no no you got to come out
here and see this and I bring her out
there by the arm I open up to you let
her by the arm I let her by the arm I
said close your eyes brought her out
into the garage next to where my
slippers are I said open your eyes she
opened her eyes and there was my car
parked in the garage and I was just
beaming I was like I was like a kid who
brought home straight A's
for the first after failing where she is
excited as you were no I'm not first
thing she said was you can't put the car
in the garage
she's right this is the lot this is the
laundry room yeah so that really I was
like she's bubble I was like just let it
stay here tonight
yeah lettuce so that get it taste that
one night it stayed there and now three
years later it's about to happen again
so one of those moments in your life
it's a milestone moment when you can say
you know what I had complete control
over my life for one fortnight that's an
illusion but it is an illusion and don't
let weekend look she's gonna come out
there and hate it again just like she
did three years ago
don't don't lead her out this time I
won't you know it's gonna just for me
don't tell anybody then the next day
I'll come home I open the garage and I'm
gonna pull on in and you know what
there's gonna be three lamps a chair and
a toy that Lando doesn't play with
anymore yeah that's what the garage is
dinosaur
the garage is the garage is the staging
area for offing things I feel I feel
like I'm fresh I feel like a fresh bag
of chips yeah don't get used to it you
know when you open that bag of chips and
you look down in it and you're like man
it's just a world of chips
I can I can find the perfect chip to eat
first I'm gonna find the one that's
folded over on itself you look into the
chips and I'm gonna eat that one eye
open and just begin eating again I it's
just I just a different way of looking
at things that's what makes it so great
it's when I open that jar of peanut
butter
take off that white seal underneath and
then I look and it's a pristine it's
like it's like the ocean on the comest
it's like a lake on the comest morning
where you could just tiptoe across it
like a ballerina that's what that peanut
butter is like in any night you know
what I'm just gonna sink my spoon and
then I'm gonna lick it clean only once
will that happen with every jar that's
true only once in three years will that
happen with my portal why don't you want
to come over I'm proud of ya
you know I think I got all I needed from
you just talking about it I really
appreciate it though I'm very happy for
you but in the in the you wanna sell
something yeah in the what is it we're
not looking for in the effort in the
Bierut in the spirit of moving along yes
I'm sorry I just a little bit we're
gonna get to this question in a second
but first I do want to let you know
about these patches now you know we'd
wrote the book of mythicality
and there is a real patch associated
with every single chapter oh yeah and we
made these patches and then there's
actual photos of the real patches that
are associated with the theme of each
chapter and they're the kinds of patches
that you can put on your buck pack
jackets and that can kind of tell a
story all together the full range of
mythicality as explained in the book of
mythicality
mythical dot store you can get all of
them you can buy them individually you
can also buy them as a pack right I
don't I don't I don't know if that's
true but just go over there and check it
out you'll figure it out you know it's
all self explanatory okay let's get into
this question I just feel so good I mean
I know that it's not healthy I don't
think like the illusion of control yeah
I don't think you should tie your your
your well-being into it I'm not but I'm
I'm not gonna resist the feeling of
feeling good because of it I'm a put it
in its place alley beat if I were to get
cryogenically frozen when what I want to
be woken up and what age would I want to
be frozen the moment that I pour I've
already answered this the moment I pull
that car into the garage you want to
freeze and freeze me freeze the whole
thing well but you don't understand he
doesn't take that moment that you're
experiencing and then freeze it forever
it just you basically die at that point
and then there's a very faint hope of
you being awakened one day okay there's
a few things here I've actually been
thinking about a lot of things related
to this okay I you know not to
short-circuit this but
cryogenics is not a thing never will be
that's my completely unprofessional
opinion I think but by the time we
figure out how to actually freeze
somebody and wake them up we will have
figured out a way to transfer the
offload people's brains a psyche into a
computer or whatever I mean are you
trying to say that you know that it's
not possible or that it won't that you
it won't be the most proficient thing to
do when you can just put it on a hard
drive that that's much more much easier
once you figure that out this will be an
archaic technique even if it is positing
that the whole point of cryogenics is to
essentially stop live forever oh I
thought you meant to stall until stuff
is figured out we're talking about
immortality ultimately here right sure
because there's there's the idea there's
the idea that in the physical world here
there's oh there there is the ultimate
goal of humanity the thing that we're
all kind of working towards with our
technology is never dying defeating
death right and cryogenics is just
another way to defeat death but I think
that some of the interesting things that
are happening in this area are gonna are
much more promising than cryogenics this
stem-cell stuff let's talk about that in
a completely uninformed way unformed
uninformed oh I will say in one sense
these rabbit hole episodes are a lot
like The Avett Brothers song with a they
talk about people love to talk on things
they don't know about let me just say
that that is what is happening here we
read enough to be a little bit dangerous
in a conversation well you let me not to
be authoritative so this is you're
talking about Mel Gibson bringing his
doctor on Joe Rogan's podcast yeah but I
don't know you know it who cares I mean
it's no I we're a podcast talking about
a podcast that we listen to
but yeah yeah I just I just I mean I
don't think that any of you come to
listen to us speak for any sort of
authoritative advice if you do I'm
really concerned for you but hopefully
you come because this is entertaining
conversation so that's what we're gonna
try to have but what thought-provoking
we listen to don't come for answers come
for thoughts we listen to Joe Rogan's
podcast and he had Mel Gibson on and Mel
Gibson brought in dr. Elkins and
brothers doctor who treated his elderly
father who was basically on his deathbed
with a bunch of problems multiple organ
failure he treated him down in Panama
because it's not legal in and the u.s.
to treat someone with the type of stem
cells that he was treated with
intravenously and maybe perhaps
otherwise but he made a dramatic
recovery and I cannot remember the word
starts with an M this is Mel mez
something there's a certain type of skin
stem cells that are basically without
getting into the specifics because we're
not going to be able to do that it can
listen to that episode of his podcast
yeah it turns out that injecting these
these stem cells both intravenously but
also directly into the problem areas is
having these incredible effects
basically what they're what they're
seeing is that young stem cells that
generate basically secrete things that
then cause the cells in older people's
bodies to behave like young cells and to
basically thinks to start happening
differently like there's things that
when you look you can look at a cell and
you can see the mitochondria you can see
these other things in it and you can
know if you know anything about cells
cell biology that oh this is an old cell
and this is a new cell new cells
multiply very quickly and and they're
healthy in all the different parts but
as we age everything becomes less
efficient and that's why you don't heal
as quickly and you don't repair yourself
and eventually you're just basically
slowly dying you know
once you hit adulthood you're basically
just slowly dying yeah Mahal Mazinger
mole cells which which are not embryonic
stem cells right again and that's what I
think let me yeah we'll say that that
stem cells were super controversial it
probably could continue to be super
controversial especially in the United
States because the impression was that
these were embryonic and they were like
taking babies and that's not at all what
this is that's not what's happening I
don't exactly know the science behind it
but it isn't that kind of thing some of
them are from the umbilical cord that
are just donated but they can also get
some cells from your own body and anyway
it's not actually a controversial thing
it just kind of feels that way but
anyway what is happening with this were
the way that it's like ultimately it's
like Mel Gibson's dad was 92 had all
these issues he's a hundred now and he's
as healthy as he's ever been and they're
doing their reversing heart disease
they're healing people who have spinal
cord injuries and this is not
pseudoscience this is not like anecdotal
evidence that you see in some wack
commercial no this is documented
peer-reviewed stuff that is happening
where people even though we are only
repeating the anecdotal evidence but no
no but yeah no but the doctor was not
right no it wasn't anecdotal okay that's
true
it's that's well documented multiple
sources has been done multiple times
like people who like the story of a guy
who was in a car wreck and could not
walk had no sensation under you know
below the vertebrae that where the
spinal cord injury was now the dude in
the dude walks around he's fine he walks
around he has full mobility full
functionality of his of his everything
below the belt and he can walk he can
run he can do anything and it's because
of these freakin stem cells that are
repairing tissue in a way that you it
was not possible for this it definitely
that conversation definitely had this
futuristic magical ring to it that's
like wow this is what it's this is what
its gonna be like
this is I mean this is gonna be such a
commonplace treatment a decade from now
it felt like the way that people were
talking about cryogenics you know years
ago talking about Joe DiMaggio freezing
himself or something like that Walt
Disney Walt Disney which that's a that's
a minute he he did not freeze himself
believe that they said that Michael
Jackson was was had a chamber before he
died but let's just that let's just say
it has it it feels the same as
cryogenics but it's much more rooted in
impressing science and without getting
into the I don't want to bore you guys I
know some of you guys when we talk about
certain scientific concepts are like
well I don't want to hear about this I
don't want to talk about that the whole
time and obviously we don't know that
much about it we just listen to the
podcast and I've read a couple of books
but let's just assume that things will
continue as they have been in this
technology
you know coupled with CRISPR and these
other things that are going to continue
to happen and develop and yeah you can
just get in so your lifestyle will be
you just get an injection or it you'll
just you'll hook up like you'll charge a
car you'll go through your portal into
your into your living room sit in your
recliner and then you'll hook up to your
IVs of your stem of the stem cells and
you just get you just get youth I know
not euthanized totally different things
yeah you look you be for all intents and
purposes let again I don't know when
this will happen but let's just assume
that there will be a point in which we
can continue human life indefinitely
okay now interesting book I told you
guys I've raved about the book sapiens
well the same guy wrote
homo Deus which is a follow-up to
sapiens which is basically looking
forward into the future mm-hmm just
started this book I'm a few chapters in
but he talks about this this issue this
the the idea of we're all kind of
trying to become immortal that's what
all this technology is kind of looking
towards and he talked about the idea of
how we mortals take risks right it's
like we go surfing which is not even
that risky but we might it might go
skydiving or to even ride in a car we do
things all the time that for certain
moments we are the probability of us
dying is greatly increased like shoot a
confetti popper at your face Zak
point-blank range and we do these things
knowing that well I'm gonna die someday
I mean you don't think about it like
that but we live in a culture where we
know that we've got 70 80 90 years and
it's over well his point was if we get
to a place where you can sustain human
life indefinitely
people are gonna become very very
different they're gonna look at risk a
lot differently because it's like man I
could get 500 years on this planet I
shouldn't go skydiving because that
could be I could be losing so my three
hundred years as opposed to well I'm
gonna die in 40 years anyway but but
then you've got like what Hollywood has
taught us about the vampire demeanor
it's sad and lonely in this it's
nihilist and defeated I mean it's like
they're just grumpy when you when you
when you live that long and you
encounter well first of all they're
encountering a lot of people who aren't
living that long so they're they're they
are lonely well and also but they're
grumpy they can only be seen they can
only come out at night they have to kill
people to live there's a lot of
negatives to being a vampire that's what
I'm never gonna be one that's yeah
that's the me of course I really don't
having control over that
I could get bit but let's just say that
it is gonna happen I mean it is
interesting to think is it are we gonna
qualify I mean I was actually on the
treadmill at the gym the other day and
I've been listening to this book and I
was like working out and I was like you
know I have to put the the information
into the treadmill so I can get my heart
rate and all this yeah
now the first week I went to the gym I
put it was like wait I was like 205 Age
forty ooh ouch yeah hurt her two strikes
type that in there without even thinking
about it I've been reading this book
third strike would be likes easy
listening music that's not an option on
the trip okay good
enjoys soft rock no it's really just
your age and your weight okay you know
what I put in I didn't even make this
connection till right now you know what
age I put in this week on the treadmill
uh
you put in a different age first of all
put in 25 are you what now the reason I
did it is because if you put in 25 the
target heart rate goes up significantly
so you have to work harder noise like if
I'm here I need to work harder but I was
also thinking I also need to work harder
like I'm a 25 year old because well if
I'm gonna live 25 year old treadmill
might kill a 40 year old man no I held
on I was sweating a whole lot more I did
realize that a 40 year old trying to be
a 25 year old on a treadmill is much
uglier to watch then a 40 year old just
being a 40 year old the first week is
just a 40 year old on a 40 year old
treadmill and I'm sweating a little bit
and I'm getting off a 40 year old on a
25 year old system I was like sweating
and making noise I had my headphones on
listening to music you could feel that
you were making 17 minutes into it I
realize you're breathing like really
loud like but then I looked around
everyone else was on headphones and they
they're all breathing and farting and
stuff nobody's listening to each other
breathing in front that's the cycle of
life but I just realized now that what
I've been thinking about is well maybe
this is gonna happen maybe maybe there
will become this time when we we solved
the the deepest mysteries of human
longevity are we gonna get are we gonna
be young enough where we can somehow be
across the threshold and be taken on
into the future and then I started
thinking do I even want that do I want
to be a vampire do I want to live to be
500 or is it or is you know 80 90 years
is that the right time to live and then
just be done then you slowed that
treadmill down to 48
you know I'm still I'm staying on 25
because I want to be healthy and trying
to get my heart in shape did you bring a
coat to the gym no I I don't I don't do
that I don't take a coat to the gym okay
whatever
okay but if I do our word inside out
that was good that was my only follow-up
question do you want to live forever and
if if you do it live forever what
happens man
I mean we talked week eight we did our
200-year plan as an exercise and in
terton internet tainment you know back
on GMM but yeah you talked about
switching careers well I think this is
it this is I mean I do think exploring
Ali's original question philosophically
well cut well kind of get it the same
thing because that is the implication
there was at what point would you want
to be frozen so that when you woke up
you could you could live from that point
forward and maybe retain like we're 40
well I'm not 40 I am 39 I'll round up
sucker you know our question was what
how much longer do we want our bodies to
deteriorate before we have the chance of
drastically slowing that down at some
point in the future if that could happen
you know it's do you want to live
forever at just degrading a lot slower I
guess so I mean it's the same experience
except like for every one day we get now
you get three I think that that seems
like an easy yes for me I don't I don't
but if there was a time in which you
were gonna be frozen let's just say that
this would work I think the question is
what age will you have lived enough of
the life on this side is it you get to
be 70 and it's just like okay well if
you get to be 80 like when does when
does life become more of a burden to
live you know and this is different for
different people but for some people
things get really really difficult past
a certain age right and you want to be
what you want to be frozen before that
point I think it
the point here's the thing you know I've
got I've got Christie who I would you
know she would have to be frozen with me
I thank you and then yeah I'd want you
to be frozen with me and then you'd want
Jesse to be frozen with you and then
maybe you know what we don't want our
kids to be frozen so we're gonna wait
for our kids to get to to develop lives
of their own and then we reach a certain
level of pride in in the in that and
knowing that they're achieving happiness
in life and that they've you know they
got their own lives now so obviously
we're not gonna freeze ourselves and
let's let our kids go through grade
school high school college without us
peace out kid yeah but if you wait until
you're old the kids have already lived
their lives you're probably a
grandfather they're adults
no but there's no point I mean when you
start to think about that it's like okay
they might keep you on their own you got
grandkids no what no the kids are on
their own you know when did they start
making a family they're all out you want
it you want to you want to be you want
to see that for you want to spec take
that from the stand you want to be
involved in that there's never a good
time for me with what's happening in my
life right now to pause it and say you
know what I'll check back in a hundred
years from now when you can figure out
how to drastically improve my quality of
life from from age 40 on well but and
then so by the time you know the people
want to be frozen I think they were
there either
they either on their way out and it's
too late or you know it's just their
life's not going well so they want to
you know hopefully wake up in an era
when it can be better well in part of
this question is you know I think the
thing that we all fear is irrelevance
right and I'm not talking about like the
irrelevance that we fear as entertainers
you know nobody cared about what we have
to say anymore but just as a person so
there are there's a just way our society
works you get to be a certain age
people just don't care what you think
anymore they care about you right so you
got like your your your your
grandparents you have three living
grandparents right mm-hmm Lincoln his
how old now 80 something 888 now you
love him unconditionally love him deeply
but he's an 88 year old man he has done
the things that he's going to do right
he's contributed 99 percent of the
things that he's going to contribute
right and he's and he's comfortable with
that he's fine with that sure but we but
at this point like you don't think of
his opinion or his perspective it
doesn't carry the same weight that it
carried when he was 58 and you were
eight or whatever right right so there's
this point in which our society has just
sort of said you get to be this age and
it's just sort of like you're old now
you matter but you don't matter at the
same time like that's just this
collective thing that people kind of do
to old people and I think that mmm
personally out of a problem almost
exclusively out of a sense of pride the
idea of just not mattering of just being
a person who is in the room at a family
gathering and it's like everybody sure
we all love grandpa Rhett we all love
him but you know we're now we're talking
about things that really matter and at
that point he kind of checks out I have
a huge fear of that now when I am 88 I
don't I'm not gonna care about that
probably I care about that now as a 40
year old because I'm like putting myself
into the body of it my 88 year old self
yeah you're having a midlife crisis well
it's not no it's not a midlife crisis
it's a fear of being old it's a fear of
being irrelevant and midlife crisis is
thinking that my life is over now I love
my life right now but I think we're
that's the that's the part of getting
old not even death just
getting old that that we fear and so
when I answer this question I'm like
well before right when I feel like
that's about to happen when I'm about to
become in what I see as irrelevant
that's when I want to check out hmm
and I you know I feel bad even talking
about it cuz I'm not trying to talk crap
about old people I'm just saying that
this is just the way you know if you're
if you're of a certain age you you can't
even get hired even if you're capable
like you know if you're white-haired
seventy year old you're just as
qualified as a brown haired thirty year
old for then you'd be like this guy he's
70 why does anyone know why does he want
to work here mm-hmm
you know just we don't we don't value we
don't feel like old people have anything
to offer I'm not saying it's true I'm
just saying that that's just the way
that well when it is true that's it's
it's a sad reality right so what do you
summarize your point I'm just saying to
answer Ally's question of when would I
want to be cryogenically frozen if this
was a real edge it a'mma thing because
you were talking I want to spectate all
these things they'll never be a point in
which I don't want to be a part of my
family's life or whatever I'm saying at
the point that I become a burden is the
point that I would want to check out and
then it'll be too late
unless assuming that when they fall you
out too in this thought exercise that
they can do something reversing which
that I think you can slow a lot but the
whole reversing thing even the stem-cell
stuff we're talking about I don't know
that that that it it seems still like a
leap to say that that would absolute
that way it would make you young it
would just make you it would make you
work best of the age we're assuming that
you're gonna basically the same thing
when you wake up and then and then
you're almost almost irrelevant when I
when I when I was frozen and now you
wake me up and I'm just irrelevant again
you know what it's analogous you know I
don't want to go in another sci-fi
direction but I am it's in lotta ways
analogous to who's going to go colonize
Mars
you know and you're not gonna take your
kids maybe you'll take maybe you take
your wife depending on the criteria and
how many people are going but um I mean
I'm talking at first at first they're
not taking a bunch of children to
colonize Mars I got I would assume not
but it's so it's people checking out of
their earth lives forever they're never
coming back they're gonna go to Mars and
so they continue to live a life but that
you you got you have to live a certain
type of life or have a certain level of
autonomy to be comfortable with I'm
gonna check out of this of this world
and and enter a new world so I think
it's there are people who are willing to
do that there are people that like you
know it I'm not one of those people you
know when you've got when you get kids
that you're investing in that's that's
that's a big factor yeah I think we're
probably talking about single but I mean
the people who volunteer to do this and
again I don't I'm kind of with Neil
deGrasse Tyson on this I don't
understand why we're thinking about
colonizing Mars when we've got a planet
that we really need to be worrying about
here that's actually habitable now but
may not be for much longer if we don't
correct things well I think we should
have all the irons in the fire and we
should have all types of people working
on all but let's just say yet but this
we're gonna be you're gonna talk about
enough brain power to go around healthy
25 year olds who are you know single or
going with their partner don't have
children they're saying bye to their
parents maybe they don't have a good
relationship with their parents I mean
you're gonna have plenty of candidates I
don't think you have to worry yeah oh
yeah but you know it's interesting
because we're talking about the ties
that we have with our family and and
this is totally natural and I'm in
complete agreement with you that as you
think about your life and you think
about what commitments you can make and
you can't make and how long you want to
live when you want to check out when you
want to be frozen you're thinking about
it in the context as a husband and a
father
mm-hmm it's gonna be very interesting I
think that a lot of our
commitments in the way that we see
family is based on our life expect our
life expectancy meaning that if we get
to a place where we can live forever are
you gonna be with the same person
forever like if you if you can
ostensibly live to be a thousand years
old and your kids that you had your kids
are gonna be nine hundred and seventy
years old you know and they're gonna
have kids and they're gonna have kids
like the way that you there's gonna is a
space issue there's a definitely space
use like some like a capacity issue but
let's put that aside let's just let's
just theoretically say that they
continue and it's maybe it's not every
thirty years maybe a generation becomes
you know a hundred years or something
like that but you're still talking about
ten generations of people are you gonna
really care like and think about how
many different think about the way that
a family tree goes you have two kids
they each have two kids H have two kids
you go ten generations we're talking
about hundreds of people who are related
to you but because you're so freakin old
it a certain point it doesn't you're
gonna have no connection to them even
though they are your direct descendants
in their content but now that you have
every reason you have an embarrassment
of riches of all these people that are
related to you but it's just it's like
walking down the street and you're like
odds are one you know I wouldn't be
surprised given the odds that this
person and I was a hair yeah you you
would you you couldn't help but not care
I think is your point it's an
interesting point listen and I again
because you can't you can't maintain
meaningful relationships with that many
people it doesn't matter what the blood
connection is right and I'm not trying
to get myself I'm not trying to get
myself in trouble I'm not trying to get
you in trouble I'm just talking
theoretically here without with our
wives you mean yes so let's just say
let's just say let's not even talk about
us let's just talk about people who are
in relationships in general Bobby do you
think and that if people can live
forever and they get married in the
first thirty year
their lives is that the expectation
culturally now the cultural expectation
traditionally speaking is that you get
married and you stay married and then
you die
right till death do us part now not
everybody does that there's a lot of
people get divorced relies of different
reasons but the cultural sort of norm is
that the expectation was that we would
be together forever even though half a
couples don't are we about to undo
everything we talked about in last
week's my see no don't think about it in
respect to your wife think about it as
Bobby and Jenny a cultural institution
there is absolutely no way that the
expectation would remain that you would
stay with the same person until you were
a thousand there isn't because that I
believe that the the expectation to
state till death do us part
is based on life expectancy coming back
to my original argument and if life
expectancy isn't a thing I just expect
my life to go on forever there's what
about some norm and I think the norm
will be based on being with somebody in
producing another generation and when
that generation is the same as you know
know the moment in which you can no
longer connect with the offspring so you
can connect with your grandkids because
that already happens you rank it rank
with your great grandkids because that
already happens there are some people
who connect with their great great
grandkids but I feel like great great
great grandkids now you're in a place
where the emotional capacity for
connection with great great great
grandkids is so low that's when you say
alright it's been great this has been an
incredible relationship and now we're
going to leave and we're going to start
and you're gonna do this well the thing
I do agree with is that it becomes like
a corporate a corporate relationship
like you're the CEO of a company when a
company gets so big this does happen the
CEO or the company can't have a
meaningful work relationship with
certain people down the struck the the
the business structure and I I just
think you know you have I don't know I
mean you and I can be very heartless so
I'm trying to channel that person
listening no no okay I know and no
here's what some people are saying right
now I'm gonna try to channel it and that
is there are fact there are people out
there who have the capacity to love
Nations of people in a way that like
we're just not love Nations
I love Nations I love I love all nations
I love all nations I love everybody I'm
just saying as a unit of measurement
there are people who their love is
unbounded I just think that although
we're talking about but very practically
like practical mechanics of actual
connections we don't limitation to the
human to a human's ability to have a
meaningful you can have a person you can
have a love for an for a nation of
people but you can't have a connection
you can't have a specific relationships
with that many individuals yeah well I
think it's 150 right there's a certain I
don't know what the number is it's the
so-and-so number because somebody some
anthropologists like determined that
just based on hunter-gatherer heritage
that the human brain has like the
capacity to have meaningful
relationships for like 150 individuals
it's just based on like tribe size
whatever but so I don't want to say
because they're also talking about it
the way I broke it down was when you
couldn't you could no longer connect
with offspring but you might be saying
but what about your what about yours the
partner that you're with isn't the love
for your partner just gonna continue and
definitely I'm just saying that the
expectation for how long the
relationship would be is that would
actually take on a much more practical
approach because here's the thing we
like to think that this is just the way
it's always been you but the fact is is
that well many different cultures in
probably most the way the the way that
relationships were formed in the distant
past where it was much different in fact
humans were much more like animals in
the distant past in that they were their
implicit miss relationships I mean that
was what the that was and when you go
back to those 150
sighs tribes it was a dude with multiple
wives you see that in all kinds of
ancient texts and and and there's lots
of archaeological evidence of that so
that was the cultural norm at the time
so what I'm saying is that if things and
the reason that it was that way is had
all kinds of factors that contributed to
what was the most efficient way to live
at the time for multiple women to pair
up with one man it was just it was the
way the dynamics work so I'm saying that
in the distant future if people are
living forever the dynamics the
expectations and the cultural norms and
what we consider to be moral will change
because it changes over time as
circumstances changed and I don't think
it's gonna be this thing where it's just
like oh well that love isn't real I know
that love was there for a certain time
and then both people are just like okay
either we continue this or we don't and
it'll be based on so many different
factors that we can't even begin like
that gets back to the when are you gonna
wake up when you're gonna be introduced
in which we talked about a couple of
podcasts ago you might wake up at a time
where so many things have changed and
we've tapped into the way our brain
works and we have no capacity to even
understand the future that we've been
put in your mind explodes and then
you're like I shouldn't have woken up
not again I agree with you not trying to
be bleak about it it's just but the the
thing about staying paired up for life
even if that's eternity and the argument
of you know 50 years together 60 years
together the type of thing of that
seeming long but and to be celebrated as
as a cultural achievement I'm just
wondering if you take it backwards to
you know like when life may so based on
life expectancy that's what makes it
awesome to sit okay
if we're gonna live this long and you're
gonna be you're gonna be partnered up
for that long that that's to be
celebrated well let's go back to life
expectancy when life expectancy was much
less and then that expect being with
somebody that long was I'm sure still
celebrated or maybe are you saying would
you say it was no big deal
when people were dying in the you know
the Black Plague or whatever it was
called well you know it is good because
then I'm saying if if you stay together
as long as you lived in relatively than
if you stayed if if you live for if life
is like these 250 years it seems like
the same principles would apply it
doesn't seem like that should change the
arguments that we were making on the
previous podcast about how you know
relationships commitment in a loving
partnership opens up a world of
experience and enrichment that just
moving to somebody else and starting
over which you know might be more
amorous it's you're missing out on
something I'm trying to make the
argument that if you act if I added
another hundred and fifty years in my
relationship with my wonderful life it
would be that much more wonderful for
ways that I could not anticipate because
that's not that's not what I'm saying
that because you you're so you're
talking about life expectancy I'm
talking about suspended animate not
suspended animation basically not aging
anymore so I was talking about
indefinite life you talked about yes I
know but I'm incremental II getting
there
so that I'm just making an argument well
let's pull back to life expectancy 250
years how do you feel about that well
that I I feel like I can make that
argument
now 500 well okay but you're also is
being a little unfair because you're
putting it in personal terms obviously
if I put it in personal terms I'm going
to say that if I were to live to be a
thousand I would stay with Jesse all a
thousand years yeah and you know what it
and we'll cut it right there and what I
said what you just said is what will sit
and now we can just talk we can just I'm
talking about it personally because my
perspective that I bring to this and
your perspective that you bring to this
is a person who's going to live to be no
more than a hundred if you're lucky and
then you're gonna die you and I live in
this timeframe we have this mindset we
have this perspective and so do our
wives at a time that has this cultural
expert let's talk about 200km you talk
about talk about 250 years now go right
back to what I said so 250 years I
when does when does the window the great
great grandkids come in definitely well
you're still 250 years and so I'm saying
that I think that that's the trigger
point at which point that the offspring
that you create would what you would
begin to lose an emotional connection
with them the offspring that you created
with this individual person because
ultimately you want to get down to the
mechanics that's kind of the purpose of
that that's sort of the ultimate
biological purpose of pairing up in a
traditional sense is to propagate the
species right that's what those desires
that's what they're kind of based in and
so if you put it into those those terms
you're making it you're making an
argument void of consciousness I mean
I'm sure a bottle bow would would feel
that well no no no no cuz you're making
that because you're trying to argue from
the perspective of someone who feels a
while feels about things the way that we
do again that's why if you ask me
personally I'll say I don't care how old
I'm gonna get I'm gonna stay with my
wife if that's the my friend but if I
were if we were born into a world where
people paired up and it was celebrated
to be in a committed I'm saying probably
ting relationship wouldn't be celebrated
for what for if even or a certain a
certain amount of time and then it was
expected to bet to break up once you hit
the what what we call it like lot 250 no
no but let's hold let's name this
threshold something that sounds cool
that the culture could really get behind
the love milestone the love miles the
love stone there's a whole ceremony
there's a stone and you rub it and all
your friends come I think all your
offspring down to your great great great
grandkids come your great
great great great grandkids don't come
because you don't care about those
stupid idiots there's too many of them
right so hundreds of people already
showing up at this friggin thing if we
were born into that skull chiral norm
where that was celebrated and then at
the at the love stone then you you part
ways amicably or not no no you know what
would happen at the love stone first of
all it would be a cultural contract it
would be a it would be a societal pact
and what would happen at the love stone
agreement is not only would you it
wouldn't be seen as a breakup again we
see all these things in a negative light
because of the time that we live in if
we if you could live to be whatever age
and you got to the love stone what would
happen at the love stone ceremony is
that that the next two people that you
were both going to pair off with would
be at the love stone ceremony that's
what a love stone ceremony would be it
would be the this couple is parting and
starting to new couples and you still be
friends but now you start the whole
process over again with someone else and
it would be celebrated culturally it
seems here's what I'm saying counter to
everything that we had but if that were
the cultural norm that I was born into
and experience my whole life I could see
that I would fall in line you know
because it's just the way it is you know
if if if you're taught your whole life
that this is the and these this is the
beauty of it and these are the ways to
celebrate it you know you know I'm
certain I could be convinced of it but
then there would be a movie there would
be a movie and it would be a movie about
it would be called be called turning
over the love stone and it would be
about this couple that got to the love
stone ceremony and they the new partners
were there and they shunned the new
partners and they started the whole
thing over again together and that would
become celebrated as the ideal because
that was turning the cultural norm on it
head and he would be seen as incredibly
controversial they they move past the
love stone they're actually talking to
their great-great great-great grandkids
that could also happen yeah I and I
think there are many people that would
state want to stay together in you and I
are two of those people absolutely it
seems like by saying that that we're
actually saying the opposite no no I
told you I'm not from a personal
perspective
you tricked me by the way you you spent
the last 15 minutes to get me on your
side about this freaking love stone yeah
and then the moment I'm like you know
what in if I was born into this cultural
norm and blah blah blah I could see that
I would fall in line and the moment I
said I was on your life and then they'd
make a movie and the awesome thing that
I would agree with with someone turning
over the love stone yeah that's you
trapped me in here is the beauty of
talking about things that will never
come to pass in our lifetime this
totally you know what you never come to
pass the release of this podcast we
can't release this yes we can right now
again this has cultural implications in
my household now is it because you
tricked me okay so what you're telling
me is that just because you your if your
wife finds out that you said that if it
was culturally acceptable for you to
only be married to her for like 300
years that you that you might call it
quits after 300 years you think she's
gonna be upset about that
well I wouldn't call it quits I'd call
it the love stone yeah the love stone
it's all positive you gotta say listen
baby we're talking about a fictitious
reality that we started talking about
based on Ali B's question that led us to
a place where we talked about a time
when humans can live indefinitely where
once you get to having great great great
grandkids you have no more capacity to
love and so there's this thing as a
ceremony called a love stone when you
get a new partner and you know what she
would say what would she say I told you
years ago to get out from
under that tall guys thoughts what I do
you act like this is my fault this isn't
my fault I'm just speaking what I
believe I'm what I'm talking about is
not what I want but what I guess would
be the truth if this were to come to
pass that's all I'm saying
my but I say my personal application is
together forever
my best guess as to what would be the
cultural norm is that it would change
because together forever is based on
forever not being that long but when
forever becomes forever forever ever
ever ever everything we think about
commitment will change and I think
that's gonna be one of the most
significant cultural questions that has
to be answered if and when we reach true
immortality which I don't necessarily
think it's ever gonna happen and I
definitely don't think we're gonna live
to see it and I don't even think that I
would want to to be completely honest
with you because I think at some point
I'm just gonna be ready to check out
even if I do have this amazing 40
year-old buddy
that runs on a 25-year old treadmill
listen you can't stroll the grocery
aisles forever at some point you're
right you got to check out I mean think
about it that's a good analogy I mean
I've been in a grocery store and the
last thing I wanted was to stay there
forever yeah but you can go to like a
super Walmart they got they got more
stuff it's kind of trashy feeling though
I mean you can go to there's so many
stores though what do you mean in my
analogy there's only one store the
stores not your wife right because he
has everything I need because that
wasn't what I was saying I I moved
beyond that I'm gonna be in the Super
Walmart for the rest of my life man
usually this plumb like alright you let
us know what you think hashtag ear
biscuits but you're not gonna listen to
this because this has been
this has been censored well here's the
thing is that you're making the
assumption that our wives listen to this
podcast they don't no they don't they
listen to us they listen that's why you
are listening lab Iran about things at
home why are they gonna why are they
gonna choose to just play a digital file
of us and let's let's be real real all
right yeah well who are we to think that
they would be offended that we would say
that they'd probably be like Halla
freaking Alou yeah yeah I don't you
think I want to be with you forever I
think that I know one of our wives is
gonna be thinking that no I I think I
think my wife would be I think she'd be
on the same page with me I think she
would say if that comes to pass the love
stone ceremony hundreds of years into
the future I get it
it's fine was she the best and you know
what well you know we can we can restore
yeah you can come back again yeah yeah
you have forever you have forever unless
she had died in a car wreck oh that's a
good point
yeah which is one of the things that I
was talking about earlier but you know
let's just assume that you're living in
like a weird bubble suit that you can't
die which that makes things awkward
right there bubble suit I just just
picture myself walking down the grocery
store aisle in a bubble suit how do I
get out of this place you can't you
can't die you're in a bubble suit can't
fit through the check out all those
magazines okay well a B or that's not
your name Ali B hopefully really
you've really dredged it up yeah I mean
this is all your fault
but you know hopefully many many years
from now somebody had a love stone
ceremony will dig this up and be like
you know the origin of this a whole idea
it's a couple of Nimrods back in 2018
talking out of their butt holes hashtag
your biscuits breathe in deep
[Music]